[موسيقى]
بنت والى المسجد النبوي تنقل هذه الحافله
الكهربائيه الصديقه للبيئه المصلين طوال
شهر رمضان كخدمه جديده تدخل ضمن اسطول
حافلات المدينه الذي قام بنقل اكثر من 300
الف راكب
[موسيقى]
تمتاز الحافله الكهربائيه بالكفاءه
التشغيليه العاليه التي تمكنها من السير
لمسافه
250 كيلومترا في الشحنه الواحده عبر مسار
مخصص يربط مطار الامير محمد بن عبد العزيز
بالمسجد النبوي الشريف تردديا بمسافه
اجماليه تصل الى
38 كيلومترا ومن المقرر ان تقدم هذه
الخدمه الجديده اكثر من 16 رحله يوميا في
مميزات كثيره عندك الشاحن المتنقل في
الحافله الكهربائيه تشحن جوالك لطفا مثلا
قطع جوالك تشحنه ثاني شيء سويت التحرك
هدوء ما في ارتجاج سهله جدا توصلك لما
تبغى صراحه اول تجربه بالنسبه للفحافلات
الكهربائيه وكثير انبسطت فيها لان صديقه
للبيئه وكمان كل الخدمات كانت كويسه
الحافله الكهربائيه تاتي ضمن مستهدفات
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للنقل والخدمات
اللوجستيه الهادفه الى تبني الوسائل
والتقنيات الحديثه في انشطه وخدمات النقل
والعمل على خفض الانبعاثات الكربونيه
بنسبه
25% ورفعي حصه استخدام وسائل النقل العام
في السعوديه الى 15% بحلول
230 من المدينه المنوره سلطان السلمي
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات